[Music]
everybody knows Romeo and Juliet that
classic Shakespeare play we were all
forced to read in middle school but what
if there was a modern retelling
happening right now live on Twitch and
tens of thousands of people tuned in for
each new installment accept our
star-crossed lovers aren't really in
love
the two rival houses are rival twitch
chats and you can affect the story if
you donate enough money kill the other
sheep did I mention that this is all
happening in Minecraft this is either
gonna go really really well
or really really really bad so I never
thought I'd be talking about a fake
minecraft relationship but this really
isn't about a fake minecraft
relationship it's about two hilarious
content creators playing on the idea of
one to create streaming magic I don't
see I don't like these covers
sorry Fitz pokey main and minecraft if
you know either of these influencers
then this collab sounds insane their
content is as far apart as you can get
pokey is one of twitches poster children
her content is clean and wholesome and
she's a sponsors dream Fitz on the other
hand while some might call him a brand
risk just go one light week without you
getting stoned and [ __ ] jack and off
that's his YouTube videos our mix of
funny but edgy jokes you probably
wouldn't show your parents basically
he's the opposite of pokey they wanna
give a kid a hit in my vape and then I
get arrested for child vape in 2018 they
indirectly crossed paths
when pokey was asked to view one of his
videos on stream one year later
pokey got her wish when her and Fitz
started streaming minecraft together and
as soon as they got into voice chat you
knew some funny [ __ ] was about to go
down oh my god I thought that was him
but it was the cow excuse me you thought
that was the cow what kind of how could
you possibly even mistake that the
result of this disaster of an idea was
comedy gold
okay $1,000 and I'll kill the couch at
$1,000 nothing what'd you say listen I
think that's against twitch tos if a guy
and a girl streamed together on Twitch
expect the chat to make things awkward
there's nothing chat loves more than
spamming memes and starting rumors and
as expected the exact same thing
happened with pokey and Fitz
of course like going into this I was
aware that I was running a strong risk
of there being an awful lot of shipping
going on and then you know once I looked
over the footage and we did a couple
more streams and it's the same kind of
banter this is all fun and games but I
could see how this can get out of hand
like very quickly you know with people
but instead of fighting these memes Fitz
and pokey leaned into it and jumped into
that fake relationship that we're now
talking about so like me and pokey main
do this stream and I like em bleeding
into this meme very heavily of like you
know you know being kind of flirty and
like you know Bruce in there and like
teas and stuff and it ends up just being
like a really [ __ ] hilarious stream
and I had a really really good time here
we are watching this fake minecraft
couple try to figure out their fake
minecraft relationship issues and
frankly it's incredible I know this is
only maybe you're a third or fourth
night hanging out and stuff but I think
hello kill the Sheep kill the Sheep
[Music]
someone donated me $50 I had to you were
talking about
I mean who hasn't been put in the
doghouse for murdering their fake
girlfriend sheep for 50 bucks
I'm gonna go to that hey Pig no no no no
no no commit don't let's not be rash
about this or it's just a sheep it's not
you scared the [ __ ] out of me you know
that is that really necessary
Jesus there's plenty of more sheep in
the yeah real mature
real mature although Fitz and pokey are
transparent about this fake relationship
the shippers still popped up I mean it's
to extremes as I just said there's that
extreme it's like they're in love
they're dating they're together I ship
it like global blood is that like like
super kind of an opposite calling
extreme then is the opposite which is
probably the more edgy side of my fan
base we're just like this were in just
like kind of just like wasn't that
serious but okay yeah now shipping is
basically fans trying to get two of
their favorite personalities into a
relationship and the shipping culture
around these two is strong I mean just
type in Fitz flirting with pokey main
into YouTube and you'll come across
dozens of video compilations how does it
feel to be my minecraft girlfriend okay
first of all I didn't know I was okay
first of all I don't notice that's what
I've had to be together for like since
the first but he is the first stream
pretty much well their minecraft
relationship might be fake
what isn't fake is Fitz is booming
twitch numbers the weird part which I
actually addressed on my stream today is
the guys who are like you know they're
like Chad's in my college who say things
like oh my god can't believe that this
is getting played by pokeyman
she's so she's so fake dude she says
she's just you know playing you for her
views if this situation has benefited
anybody 6000 subscribers like my
analytics are going [ __ ] crazy my
videos were popular I'm making mad
revenue I scream like the other week
with her I got like a thousand subs in
the stream yeah yeah
the man is killing it on Twitch he was
the fifth fastest growing channel in
September and his followers hours
watched and viewercount have all
skyrocketed since these streams with
pokey people can't wait for the next
pokey fit stream and they make that note
I think that like people who watch pokey
streams are probably getting a bit sick
of my name being spammed there Chapman
Brown here come the hooking this frogs
again and yeah I mean likewise when I
stream is they get this like such bad
like they'll be okay for like 20 minutes
and then notice I like getting them
nervous where's pocket
Percy these minecraft streams are just
the start for Fitz and pokey
they've already branched into other
games which come with their own
hilarious challenges alright take this
and figure this one out
let's use their eyes that's step one it
would be wrong to simply call them a
fake minecraft couple because pokey and
Fitz are twitches very own comedy duo
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
you
[Music]